c'est l'image qui représente sans doute
le mieux l'oeuvre du père pedro en
arrière-plan une décharge et l'homme de
foi suivie par une multitude d'enfants
l'album porte le nom de l'association
humanitaire à cammas ou fondée en 1989
par pedro opeka père de la congrégation
de saint vincent de paul père pedro a
sauvé du dépotoir d'antananarive des
milliers d'enfants malgaches avec des
auteurs des bulles dans l'océan
l'éditeur jean luc schneider a voulu
raconter l'histoire de cet argentin que
le ciel a envoyé en mission sur terre
c'est un personnage quand même assez
atypique
le truculent être footballeur
professionnel entre autres mais voilà et
donc c'est ce chemin qu'on a voulu
mettre en avant et démontrer que cela
s'est fait sur 30 ans a été facile
puisque la bande dessinée montre à quel
point il ya eu quand même des
oppositions et des difficultés avant et
puis ça montre aussi un modèle que je
trouve vertueux plus qu'en fait ce n'est
pas de l'assistanat c'est un travail de
responsabilité partagée des auteurs
professionnels qui maîtrisent les
techniques spécifiques de la bande
dessinée jean luc schneider s'est
entouré des meilleurs pour produire cet
album tiré à dix mille exemplaires dont
4000 sont distribués à la réunion un
album financé par des amis du père pedro
dans l'ue là ça permettra en vendant ses
bd
au père pedro d'avoir l'intégralité de
la vente pour pouvoir subvenir etc
continué son action lab à madagascar à
cammas ou l'humanité par l'action fait
déjà parler d'elle dans la presse
nationale qui salue le travail du
lazaristes argentin qui a bâti village
et écoles autour de la décharge
d'andralanitra le père pedro qui fêtera
dans quelques jours son 73ème
anniversaire est nominé pour la sixième
fois au prix nobel de la paix